[Música]
llegó el momento de la información
económica en France 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido vamos a
iniciar hablando de la economía
Argentina porque el gobierno hoy sí
confirmó estos rumores del nombramiento
de Sergio más allá lo titulado antes la
prensa y va a ser el nuevo ministro de
economía El Clarín de hecho fue el
primero que lo adelantó y el cargo es
llamado super ministro precisamente
porque va a dirigir el Ministerio de
economía el de desarrollo productivo y
también el de agricultura el nuevo
ministro estará a cargo de las
relaciones con los organismos
internacionales bilaterales y
multilaterales de crédito la actual
ministra de economía Silvina avataque y
se habría puesto su renuncia Por ahora
se desconoce cuál será su función en el
gobierno o si saldrá del mismo ataques
duró menos de un mes en el cargo y llegó
ahí después de la renuncia de Martín
Guzmán nuestro periodista Luis Muñoz nos
preparó un repaso de la situación
económica de ese país
protestas en el campo
protestas en la ciudad y dos gráficas el
tipo de cambio oficial ha llegado a los
130 pesos por dólar mientras la
inflación ha alcanzado el 64%, los
pronósticos indican que podría llegar al
90% para diciembre una caída que se ha
acelerado en el último mes Con una
devaluación del peso del 40%. entre las
causas problemas externos como el
fortalecimiento del dólar o la invasión
de Rusia a Ucrania pero también
estructurales como la escasez de Divisas
las expectativas de devaluación el
déficit fiscal y especialmente la
incertidumbre política precisamente el
principal detonante del hundimiento fue
el repentina dimisión el 2 de julio del
ministro de economía Martín Guzmán quien
era garante del acuerdo de enero para
una reestructuración de la deuda de 44
mil millones de dólares con el fondo
monetario internacional
le daba entonces un 3,6% de crecimiento
el segundo país de América Latina
después de Colombia eran otros tiempos
la crisis de gobierno entre el
presidente Alberto Fernández y la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández están
debilitando la economía Argentina puesto
que en la discusión está la forma de
enfrentar la crisis con un kirchnerismo
que se opone al acuerdo con el fmi
con la confianza por los suelos El
Ejecutivo se aferra que quedan entre
13.000 y 18.000 millones de soja de
exportación sin liquidar y a un descenso
del consumo de gas cuando mejoren las
temperaturas en primavera
Jorge y se cumplió un año en Perú de la
llegada del presidente Pedro Castillo
Cómo ha sido su gestión en lo económico
bueno Pese a que algunos indicadores
económicos Fueron golpeados por un
contexto internacional como el alza del
dólar o la guerra en Ucrania varios
analistas también apuntan a lo coyuntura
interna a un año marcado precisamente
por la inestabilidad política que ya ha
pasado cuentas a la economía conversamos
hace unos minutos con Luis Miguel
Castilla él es economista peruano y ex
ministro de economía y finanzas del Perú
le preguntamos Cómo impactó esta
inestabilidad política en lo económico
esto Dijo En general la Prisma la prima
de riesgo regulatorio se ha incrementado
en el país hay ahora mucha mayor
inseguridad jurídica que ha orientado a
la inversión y en general El Perú queda
considerado un país Muy atractivo de la
inversión
digamos ha dejado de serlo la inversión
privada se ha detenido en su crecimiento
y la perspectiva Es que la privada se
contraiga este y el próximo año
un indicador muy importante es la
calificación crediticia del país ha
tenido una reducción este año y las
alarmas digamos sean se han disparado Y
esto no se condice con los buenos
fundamentos macroeconómicos del país
entonces hay hoy en día una gran duda
Respecto a los problemas de
gobernabilidad y la falta de acuerdos
políticos de de de de de de eso de
mínimos consensos de cómo salir de un
entrampamiento político e institucional
en el país y esto le pasa factura
obviamente a inversores que buscan un
mínimo de estabilidad para apostar
capital en países como como el Perú
vamos ahora Norteamérica porque en
Estados Unidos la Casa Blanca defiende
la fortaleza de la economía
estadounidense Y descarta una vez más
una recesión el presidente continuó
desestimando estas afirmaciones de que
Estados Unidos estén recesión argumenta
que existe un mercado de trabajo
históricamente fuerte junto con un
sólido gasto de los consumidores y la
inversión empresarial esto porque hoy
precisamente se presentaron el informe
sobre el producto interno bruto que
muestra una contracción económica entre
abril y junio por segundo trimestre
consecutivo a un ritmo anual del 0,9%.
técnicamente dos trimestres consecutivos
de caída del pib constituyen un
indicador informal aunque no definitivo
de una recesión Bueno pues Jorge usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación lo
invito a que se quede con nosotros que
ya vamos a
directo